- [Gary] Great
meetings all day long.
You know trying to create
some meatiness to
this episode, Tyler.
Otherwise you're gonna have
a tough time but editing it.
(tape rewinding)
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
Good morning Instagram.
It's me Gary.
Instead of a motivation quote or
some sort of clip just want to
go camera to face.
Just tell you how much I
appreciate you. All of you guys.
Your attention
means the world to me.
I'm humbled by the thousands
of emails and DM and tweets and
comments on YouTube and the
value that I'm bringing to you
and your feedback
is the value you bring to me.
I'm just so thankful.
So thankful for everything
that's going on and wish you
guys the best week.
Happy Monday.
It's gonna be the best week of
your life especially if you take
the bull by the horns.
Just fucking take control.
Take it.
Have a great week.
("Victoria" by Sonder)
This is something I've
spent a lot of time on.
Because I was gonna go right
after it as a media company and
this is such a
natural for this company.
So, anyway, we should win this.
It'd be stupid not to.
And honestly, I think that's the
punchline of this episode which
is like look I think the thing
that is really fascinating about
this vlog and about being an
executive at this scale is
there's some days that
are enormously predicated on
conversations that I can't share
with the world but I can give
you some themes.
I think the thing that people
need to remember is if you're
running a business you're either
going to be financially based in
the short term or the long term.
Think one of the themes for me
today is being an executive is
I continue to be proud of the
fact that I make decisions for
the long term because unless
I'm looking to sell my business,
which I'm not,
there're always going to
be long term games, right?
So why make decisions, you know,
so many of you are going to run
into money for the first time
this year and you're gonna make
$130,000 instead of $60,000 for
the first time and what you're
gonna do is go buy stuff.
You know you've
been waiting so long.
This is a good way to cut in
the #AskGaryVee
with Eric today, right?
Hey everybody it's
Gary Vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 243 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
Erik Wahl, welcome to the show.
Thrilled to see you my man.
He talks about
getting used to patience.
- I've learned more patience in
the last 12 months than I've had
to endure my whole life.
- Woah, woah, woah.
Before we get into
this phone call, I'm sorry.
In the last 12 months?
- Yeah.
Should I get comfy on the couch?
- Do the psychology thing.
- You intrigued me.
Yeah, tell me that.
Or his struggle with loving
every part of the journey or
I've put in so much work,
don't I deserve now to cash in?
The answer is sure.
- I thought my
brand was gonna launch.
I thought that I've done the 10,
12 years of slaving away doing
100 shows a year.
Logging 250,000 miles--
- That assumes you went out
where they did the videos and
all this that you know, huh.
Dude, shit, man.
Fuck, you can cash
in anytime you want.
The problem is when
you cash in you cash in.
And what do I mean by that?
I mean that the second you cash
in your taking money out of the
kitty that can be in investing
and you're converting it into
something short term
which is your prerogative.
Like do you but
one of the missions
I have here is to teach
people how to build big things.
Honey Empire and the way you
build big things is continue to
invest in those things and
so today's themes were very,
very heavy on how do I and
why do I continue to invest in
divisions, agendas, people.
- Stay the course.
- [Gary] It's all that and right
but being somebody who's scaled
so much in his life it's
about the unscalable scalable.
- Totally.
- [Gary] Strategies,
infrastructure, departments.
I mean today was a
full day of not being and
you know it's funny.
You caught any of
the film of me and Allen?
The CFO from afar?
- [Other Tyler] Mhmmm.
- Perfect.
That meeting in the middle or
the beginning of the day is
very much short term.
Here are the financial
realities you're dealing with.
Can you afford to
invest in everything?
And the answer is yes and no
and so I think the balance
of where you're going
and what you want in the short
term versus the long term is a
difficult one for all of us.
But I do implore all
of you that are watching,
I implore all of you watching,
the more you can invest in the
long term, the more you will win.
Do a recall a little bit
to Tony Robbins's quote from
#AskGaryVee
about the market here.
- 80% of those corrections
never become a bear market.
They all correct
back just like last year.
But if you sold, you lose.
- Of course.
- But then let's
look at the crash.
Crashes happen every
five years on average.
We've gone eight without one,
that's why we're due for one.
- Mhmmm, mhmmm.
- And you're right
to be somewhat prepared,
but while you're preparing,
there's opportunity that's
happening because, first of
all, every bear market lasts on
average a year.
("Memo" by Sonder)
- That's right.
- And here's the one
thing I want people to hear,
in two centuries
of American Business,
every single bear market was
followed by a bull market.
So you remember 2008,
and people lost 50 percent?
- This is where--
- It went up 69%.
- If you take the money out of
the market over the long term
you tend to lose.
If you decide to make more
profit in your business this
year because you
want to buy something,
those are dollars you can't
use to build your foundation.
I think a lot of you are
building very small businesses
or smaller than your
ambition is because you need
too much in the short term.
You're taking too much out in
the short term and so I continue
to be very passionate
and very, very focused
on investing in the
long term at the expense of
some of the short term luxuries.
Maybe I can't have some of
the things that I want but I've
noticed some of you saying
GaryVee it's cool to see you
take an economy seat in a plane.
Or it's super funny
to not see you be fancy.
It's because I'm
investing in my future.
You know if I go private jet for
$15,000 instead of economy for
$500 that's $15,000 that I can
invest in the longer term and so
instead of having a private
jet I end up the New York Jets.
And so, what's really important
about you guys following this
journey I hope, what
I hope my legacy is
is that not only am
I talking in this rant about
long term investment you'll be
able to actually physically
watch this over the next 5 to
10, 15 years of what
long term investment means.
In relationships
like my man Babin here.
In strategies of a lot of behind
the closed door meetings where
today I made decisions that are
not in my best interest short
term and really in just
the way I live my life.
Financially, professionally
and as a dude.
Really speaks so I don't
charge you guys for stuff.
I don't want your
short term dollars.
I want your season tickets
to the New York Jets one day.
Goes down 33 percent, but you
don't lose 33 unless you sell--